thank you very much Ted the weather
creating some dangerous driving
conditions in California multiple roads
closed near Bakersfield and Mojave due
to the weather and that weather
responsible for the closure of the I-15
at times today as well Victoria Saha
joins us live near Prim with the very
latest status on what's happening out
there right now Victoria
Kirsten it's clear here right now but
throughout the day it's been windy which
made that winter weather feel even more
brutal but right here by Prim the gas
stations had people stopping by fueling
up before they headed back onto the road
again but this time they hope that fuel
would last them just in case they got
stuck
a cold and wet start to the morning for
drivers going in and out of Nevada to
California the winter weather causing
for slick roads that ended up shutting
I-15 down for hours driver Jesse Grasso
from Temecula California isn't used to
weather like this it's all getting out
of the car and hanging out and stuff
yeah we're getting out yeah hanging out
in the snow and whatnot there's 18
wheelers stuck in the middle of the road
Grasso is on his way to Idaho and is
hoping for no more delays due to the
weather but he says he is grateful for
his four-wheel drive pickup truck
drive pickup truck
so while we were here throughout the day
we saw several cars and semis taking it
slow on the road the highway closure
also made some items for restaurants not
available because they told me that they
didn't get deliveries in time from those
truck drivers because I-15 here was
closed reporting in Prem Victoria saw 8
News Now